all right welcome everybody uh
bernie sanders has kept the senate in
session
and there is a debate starting right now
over
uh a vote on the veto of trump's defense
bill possible debate about the two
thousand dollar payments let's just
first see
uh what mitch mcconnell is saying and
then we'll talk each household
needs the help whether or not their
finances have changed
dramatically this past year oh he sounds
terrible
yesterday secretary mnuchin announced
households should begin receiving these
payments as early as today
and this week that is more good news
to a lot of people after congress and
the administration finalized the
bipartisan bill the president expressed
interest in further expanding
non-targeted direct payment
so to ensure the president was
comfortable signing the bill into law
the senate committed to beginning one
process that would combine three of the
president's priorities
larger direct checks a repeal of section
230 of the communications tradition
so this is the poison pill that mitch
mcconnell is setting up let's listen and
then i'll explain
three of the president's priorities in
one senate process
that was the commitment and that's what
happened yesterday when i introduced
texts reflecting just what the president
had in fact requested the poison pill
now mr president house and senate
democrats want something
very different as they tried to do
countless times in the past four years
speaker pelosi and leader schumer are
trying to pull a fast one on the
president and the american people
first of all they're hoping everyone
just forgets about election integrity
so remember that it trump wants the two
thousand dollars
it's not oh oh nancy and chuck are
trying to pull a fast one well
tr why aren't you addressing the fact
that trump wants the 2000.
democrats are trying to warp what
president trump
actually laid out well warp two thousand
dollars two thousand dollars that's very
precise the wisdom of borrowing hundreds
of billions more to send
out more non-targeted money including to
many households that have suffered
no loss of income during the crisis
covet 19 has not affected all households
equally
not even close it's hardly clear that
the federal government's top priority
should be sending thousands of dollars
to for example
a childless couple making well into six
figures who've been comfortably
teleworking all year
so what he's picking out there is if you
have two
if you have a couple where each person
makes 70k
they make 140 which puts you under the
150 limit for a couple
and the argument is they they'd be fine
with 1200 they don't need four grand but
of course
th this is a completely myopic and
ridiculous argument where
you always any time they want to justify
not giving people money
they this is the equivalent of reagan's
welfare queen
with a cadillac 12 kids or whatever
who never existed right this is how they
always attack
the so-called free ridership issue with
any kind of social insurance it's
important not to fall for it
you always have to draw the line
somewhere no matter where you draw the
line
you could say well what about this
example just on one side of the line or
this example just
on the other side of the line not new
speaker pelosi and democratic leader
could look at households in new york and
california who make three hundred
thousand dollars
in households where nobody has been laid
off where earnings did not even drop
during the past year again this
all of this he's talking about you know
couples with no kids
who are doing okay because they work
from home which of course is not the
majority of the people that are that are
targeted by this seize the game here
these are the same democrats who
probably blocked the entire aid package
for a
month oh god because that remember
that's a lie
in may the democrats already had
proposals rokhana had a proposal
you know we i you guys are too informed
to fall for that
thousand dollars regardless of whether
they've experienced any disruption
at all this past year
even the liberal washington post today
is laughing at the political left for
demanding more huge giveaways
with no relationship well people getting
banned already
here's what the washington post wrote
especially wrong-headed
is the progressive left spearheaded by
senator bernie sanders who has cell
phones
thirty thousand dollars is aid to
desperate americans despite huge amounts
destined for perfectly comfortable
families
that's from the editors of the
washington post
the wall street journal usually their
opposite number actually agrees
these non-targeted checks are
unnecessary and struggling households
can access targeted support like
expanded jobless benefits
food stamps child care subsidies and
much more
i mean food stamps is silly food you you
actually
many of the people that are targeted by
something for those earning under 75k
um are they make too much to get food
stamps like
this is a sort of uh uh it's it's sort
of like a verbal diarrhea gish gallop
kind of thing we're none of this this is
not a coherent speech as you probably
can tell
back to its pre-pandemic levels if not
higher if specific struggling households
need still more help
after the huge historic package that was
just signed into law four days ago
huge connections taking effect and what
they will need
is smart smart targeted aid
not another fire hose of borrowed money
that encompasses other people fargos who
are doing
just fine so in my view colleagues like
senator cornyn
and senator toomey have pointed this out
persuasively
but more broadly here's the deal
the senate is not going to split apart
the three issues that president trump
linked together just because
democrats are afraid to address two of
them oh that is funny the senate's not
going to be bullied into rushing out
more borrowed money into the hands of
democrat
rich friend imagine having the audacity
to talk about
borrowed money when trump has exploded
the deficit more than
any president in history yet borrowed
money
and a lot more targeted relief for those
who need help
the most we're going to stay smart
we're going to stay focused and we're
going to continue delivering
on the needs for our nation
now mr president i move to proceed to
calendar number 480s
3985
the clerk will report the motion
motion to proceed calendar number 480 as
39.85
a bill to improve and reform policing
practices accountability and
transparency
i understand that there are two bills of
the dust due second reading and block
[Music]
clerk will read the titles of the bills
for the second
time s 5085
a bill to amend the internal revenue
code of 1986 to increase the additional
2020 recovery rebates to repeal section
230 of the communications
act of 1934 and for other purposes
hr 9051 and act to amend the internal
revenue code of 1986
to increase recovery rebate amounts to 2
000
for individuals there it is and for
other purposes
in order to place the bills on the
calendar on the provisions of rule 14
i'd object to further proceeding in law
objection having been heard the bills
will be placed on the calendar
[Music]
so mitch wanted the discussion of that
2000 done away with there was an
objection so now it will be put on the
calendar
i was prepared this afternoon to speak
about the business
the senate must address and i will do
that but
first i must respond to the recent
announcement by the junior senator from
missouri that he intends to contest the
certified votes
okay this was the other thing i was
going to talk with you guys about votes
next week the process for electing
american presidents is provided for in
our constitution and laws
the process has been followed fully
fairly
the results have been duly certified by
the governors of the states and they
have been reviewed and confirmed by the
courts
many times over the result is that
joe biden and kamala harris won the
election by overwhelming margins
in both the popular vote and electoral
vote
the biden-harris ticket received more
than 81 million votes
more than any ticket in american history
that was over seven million more votes
okay so we're kind of kind of following
the generalities of the proceedings here
i don't know that we need to um
listen to every every word but let me
tell you guys what's going on
so we we have three very here's the
schedule basically for next week as as
we enter
2021 these these uh streams have all
been scheduled
so monday and i'm leading up to what
what is being discussed monday night
we will have uh donald trump's final
rally
before leaving office okay this has
already been
scheduled and this will be in georgia on
monday night
tuesday night we are going to have for
you live
results from the georgia senate election
that's tuesday night
and then wednesday january 6th we this
is all scheduled it's all on the channel
we'll be live
streaming all of these elements on the
sixth
is the formal vote uh the formal
counting of the vote
okay of the electoral vote which will be
presided over
by vice president mike pence now we
expected
that there would likely be some
republicans in the house
who would stand up and object to the
counting of certain
votes or maybe the totality maybe in a
certain
state in the house what we have now
learned is that
one republican senator josh hawley who's
disgusting i mean the worst of the worst
uh of what exists um he plans to stand
as a member of the senate in objection
to the counting
of certain electoral votes and when that
happens when you have an objection in
the house
and an objection in the senate the joint
session
which is house and senate together they
separate
and they do two hours of debate in the
house and two hours of debate in the
senate
before each body votes as to whether
they want to sustain
this objection preventing a counting of
the ballots or not
now a couple of different uh a couple of
different things
to to talk about here first of all
this is not going to change the outcome
of the election
okay so i think it's important for me to
just remind you that this is a coup
attempt
that it is it's not going to work so for
people who are still very very
anxious um you can you can relax
however it's possible that there are
going to be
a number of different attempts and the
the concern is that these may combine
with violence from those unwilling to
accept
the reality um but but so
the the expected schedule would be
1p east 10a west on wednesday we're
going to have all of this live for you
and i hope you'll you'll cover it with
us
the process will start with mike pence
who's scheduled to leave the country
hours after this is done on on wednesday
um
they are going to start this process
josh hawley is expected to object
some members of the house are expected
to object this will temporarily
temporarily stop the the count
and the pot the bodies will separate and
debate on their own now how long that's
going to go
on wednesday i don't really know but
that's the gist of what we are
expecting okay so let's listen to a
little more of chuck schumer i have
super chats to read i have vaccine
updates i have a whole bunch of
different things to talk about because
it doesn't address an unrelated social
media issue
think about it for a moment the
president vetoed a pay raise to living
american soldiers
in order to defend the honor of dead
confederate
traitors well the senate will soon have
an opportunity to override the
president's objection
and do right by those brave americans
who wear the uniform
now as i said yesterday there are two
two major issues
before the senate right now the annual
hey guys honestly um there's a there's a
million streams of this that
that you can go and watch so you know
people just telling me to shut the f
up you're just getting banned it's just
silly like the this is this is my
channel you understand right like if you
just want to stream with no commentary
go to c-span
there's a very simple solution to this
dilemma
leader mcconnell should bring both
measures up for a vote
and let the chips fall where they may i
believe both measures
the nd defense override
and the two thousand dollar checks to
american families will both
pass but at the very least the senate
deserves the opportunity for an up or
down vote
on increasing the individual payments to
the american people
so at the end of my remarks i will ask
the senate to set a time tonight
for a vote on the house bill could be a
long day to provide
two thousand dollar checks the
republican leader objected to a similar
request i made yesterday and it appears
he may be considering a different bill
that packages stimulus checks with other
unrelated and partisan policies
so i want to be very clear about one
thing
there is no other game in town
beside the house bill the only way
the only way
to get to the american people the two
thousand dollar checks they deserve
and need is to pass the house
bill and pass it now
the house is recessed for the year any
modification or addition to the house
bill cannot become law
before the end of this congress true the
way to kill
to kill the bill make no mistake
about it either the senate takes up and
passes the house bill
or struggling american families will not
get two thousand dollar checks
during the worst economic crisis in 75
years
and they're not going to get them over
the past few days days
the idea of increasing direct payments
to the american people
has united folks from all points of the
political spectrum
and i salute the senator from vermont
for the good job he has done
that's bernie bringing this forward to
the american people's
attention and overwhelming bipartisan
majority in the house
supports the two thousand dollar checks
senate democrats
strongly support these 2000 checks
trump and our unlikely ally president
trump this morning tweeted
two thousand a s a p
for once democrats agree with something
on president trump's twitter feed
let's send two thousand dollars asap
working americans who are facing the
hardest and darkest days of the pandemic
after all the insanity that senate
republicans have tolerated from
president trump
his attacks on the rule of law and
independent judiciary the
conduct that led to his impeachment is
this
where senate republicans are going to
draw the line
two thousand dollar checks to the
american people
that is a bridge too far please
for the awareness of my colleagues we
can have this vote tonight
and send the bill directly to the
president's desk for signature
we can vote on the ndaa bill tonight and
finish the senate's business before the
end of the year
business all it takes is our republican
colleagues
consenting to a simple vote on the house
bill
to provide two thousand dollar checks to
the american people
yes or no up or down
do you support sending two thousand
dollars
to the american people or not let's
have the vote and so
mr president i i i ask unanimous consent
that's not going to the senate proceed
to the immediate consideration
of h.r 9051 a bill received from the
house to increase recovery rebate
amounts to two thousand dollars for
individuals
that the bill be read a third time and
passed and the motion to re
be to reconsider be considered made and
laid upon the table
with no intervening action or debate
is there objection object objection is
heard
under the previous order the leadership
time is reserved
under the previous order the senate will
be in a period of morning business with
senators permitted to speak therein for
up to two
don't you guys get the feeling that
these are all people really working hard
for what's best for the american people
great use of tax time huh let's listen
to bernie
what senator schumer schumacher said
and what he said goes beyond economics
it goes beyond the desperation that they
should be good of millions
of working families are facing
it goes beyond the struggles of the
people of vermont or kentucky
and let me just make it clear for the
majority leader
that 10 out of the poorest 25
counties in the united states of america
are located in kentucky
so maybe my colleague the majority
leader might want to get on the phone
and start talking
to working families in kentucky and find
out how they feel
hey mitch just won he's good for six
years his constituents will have
forgotten about this by then
two thousand dollar check per adult
and i have the strong feeling that the
people of kentucky
will respond no differently than the
people of vermont or new york
this last poll that i saw i have 78
of the american people saying that they
wanted and needed that type of help
but this discussion frankly
is not just about the economic
struggling of working families in this
country it's not just
the massive levels of income and wealth
inequality it's about basic democracy
now what we have to do here on the floor
whether it's
senator schumer or senator mcconnell or
me we've got to talk in legalese that's
the language
of the united states senate and this
stuff sounds pretty complicated
to the average person but all that
senator schumer and i are asking
of the majority leader is a very simple
request allow the members of the united
states
senate to cast a vote
understand mitch isn't suppressing the
payments he's he's even suppressing just
a vote on the payments i see senator
toomey here he has been
clear about it i suspect he will vote
against it i respect
his opinion but all that we are asking
for
is a vote what is the problem
in the house over two-thirds of the
members of that body including 44
republicans voted
to say that at this time of economic
desperation
working families deserve help
and they deserve a two thousand dollar
check
bernie calling for the slides senator
schumer just indicated
we have a very unlikely my favorite
thing about the senate is these huge
oversized printouts i always disagree
with trump more times than i have and
yet here is what the leader of the
republican party says
he says two thousand dollars asap
so i don't love the use of cropping i
think some of the negative spaces is
miscalibrated but i still like it for
comedic value
so what all of this comes down to
my fellow americans it's not even
whether you agree with senator schumer
and myself
and 78 percent of the american people
would you agree with senator mcconnell i
suspect senator toomey that's fine
it's called democracy we have
differences of opinion
all that i am asking is give
us a vote what's the problem
allow the united states senators to cast
the vote
as to whether or not they are for the
two thousand dollar check or whether
they're against it
we will need as i understand there's 60
votes to win
that's a big hurdle i don't know that
we're going to win
there are a number of republicans
through their credit yes
mitch mcconnell doesn't want republicans
being put on record
in conflict with trump
maybe we will lose i think that would be
unfortunate
but all that i am asking for right now
is
give us the opportunity to vote what is
the problem
with that so mr president
with that i will now go to senate
legalese
and say quote i ask unanimous consent
that at 11 30 a.m on thursday december
31st
right the senate proceed to the
immediate consideration of hr
9051 to provide a 2 000
direct payment to the working class
object that the bill be considered read
a third time
and the senate vote on passage of the
bill without intervening action or
debate
further that if passed the motion to
reconsider be considered
made and laid upon the table further
that immediately follows
the vote on hr 9051 the senate proceed
to the immediate consideration
of the veto message on hr 6395 that the
senate immediately vote on passage of
the bill the objections of the president
to the contrary notwithstanding
with no intervening action or debate
is there objection mr president the
senator for pennsylvania
mr president reserving the right to
object
let me start by pointing out
we are not in the same place that we
were in
back in march no or worse our economy is
in nothing like
the situation we faced during a moment
in march when this body came together
and voted unanimously i believe
for the most extraordinary aid package
financial stimulus to characterize it
in the history of the world by far
remember where we were
i think just about every other european
country plus canada
plus many other asian countries would
disagree with that enemy had stopped
functioning
because state governments around the
country
decided they had to close it down we can
discuss
we can argue about whether that was a
good decision or not but given the
limited
knowledge we had about the nature of the
covet 19 threat
it was deemed to be the right thing to
do sorry so we're going to mute this for
a bit as as you know you know
i don't think we need to listen to every
one of these toxic republican screeds
but
the republicans don't even want to vote
on the two thousand dollar check so i i
will mention a few different things
um if you're just joining us what
democrats are asking for here is just a
vote on the two thousand dollar
checks and republicans are doing
everything they can to
object to that okay democrats would like
a vote tomorrow morning at 11 30 a.m
eastern time
uh new year's eve right before um
wrapping uh for for the year quite
literally
now in the middle of all of this we are
starting to see
the vaccination program
extremely slowly build
where the united states now has
vaccinated
2.32 million people on a first
dose that's 0.7 percent
of the population and at the current
rate
it would take 10 years 10 years
to reach herd immunity we're vaccinating
about 1 million people per week
and we need to be vaccinating 3.5
million per day so that's where we are
right now
now meanwhile the numbers are again very
ugly with 3 400 deaths
yesterday as some of you may remember we
did have this dip
right around the holiday and it
in all likelihood is just a reporting
dip
and i expect that we will see it spike
again i'm expecting the spike
on cases uh to sort of end or to start
diminishing more permanently
around january 10 to january 15 and then
from the standpoint of deaths as you can
see we did have
this uh dip during during the holiday
but then spiking yesterday and my
expectation is deaths will peak
right around february 1st which will be
a just a beautiful beautiful
um birthday gift for uh for me
right around that time so that's where
we are right now
and um every indication that republicans
are sort of done
with uh with all of this and they will
do the best they can
just to object to everything so let me
get uh
as we just you know i don't think we
need pat toomey's rant
we'll get back to the procedure once uh
democrats continue
trying to actually move a uh move this
forward
i do want to say thank you to the six
people who grabbed
twitch subs during the uh intervening
time
and also a big thank you to jamie
danielle
knox who signed up at jointpakman.com
and his new member number seven today
now
it is believed i i don't know if you
guys know this
it is on the agenda for the senate here
that
after they deal with the two thousand
dollar payments they are expecting
to ask for passage with unanimous
consent
to ban all of my membership discounts
above 50 starting in the new year
i do expect objections bernie wants
those
discounts so i'm told bernie will object
but there will be an effort made to do
that
so the point is this is a great
opportunity before the year is out to
take advantage of that coupon code fresh
start
for 70 off a membership at
jointpakman.com we know bernie's with us
on the discounts
but unfortunately uh there is a
movement a concerted movement to wrap
that in with section 230
and decimate quite literally decimate
our membership so
that is upcoming all right let me read a
few super chats i don't want to miss
these as as we
wait for pat toomey to turn this back
over marika says thanks for your sane
reporting during this insane year
how are the two seats in georgia polling
is it looking good or excellent
uh a ps good haircut yeah i did get a
haircut it very very badly needed
um listen i i think it is going to be a
real uphill battle to win both of those
seats in georgia
if i were a betting man i would say
democrats get one
i think two is a big uphill battle and i
think we've got to get every every vote
out
uh very very important chakaseki says
should we expect
congressman letlow's twitter account to
posthumously continue to tweet like the
ghost of herman cain
yes uh oh hold on let's go back here
senator for massachusetts
thank you mr president very much and i
rise to
echo the sentiments of the senator from
vermont
he is right ed markey the republicans
are wrong
on this issue on every single part of
this debate senator sanders is right
the republicans are wrong right we're in
the middle
of a unprecedented crisis in our country
we have a health care crisis we have an
unemployment crisis
we have a hunger crisis we have a
housing all right so no malarkey markey
outlining the situation and we have a
sense of what he's going to say
uh yeah uh congressman elect letlow died
of covid
and uh chakaseki pointing that out
uh tell him bernie says trish
devanimation says these people are okay
with giving 82 billion to universities
and private schools but not even enough
for one month's rent to individuals that
it's the unfortunate reality
aaron calling mitch mcconnell a foppish
dandy
wow nicole says happy new year
amy says 2k would be a godsend i'm on
food stamps and only make 8k a year 10k
loans georgia please vote blue please
and then jacob congratulating me on the
uh haircut i appreciate that um
we you know i i i know that there are
people still holding out hope
but i don't expect that uh this two
thousand dollar
vote is even going to going to go
anywhere
it's unfortunate but i i wish i were
more optimistic about it
thanks to brian dezurich for signing up
at joinpakman.com let's get back to a
little bit of ed markey here
to create a vaccine but because
for seven months the republicans have
refused to fund the public health system
of our country at the state and local
level
we have operation snail speed
to put the vaccinations in the arms of
the american people
yep it was anticipatable
tony fochy and others were warning us
back in may in june and july there would
be a second wave and the second wave
could be bigger we got the warning
the republicans refused to heed
that warning and here we are now without
the public health infrastructure
to deal with the overflow capacity
in emergency rooms and icus all across
the country
while simultaneously asking those same
medical institutions to put vaccinations
in the arms of healthy people without
the resources provided by the federal
government to help those states and
local communities
to deal with that crisis
sometimes daniel patrick one hand would
say
that when you deal with an issue you
deal with it
with benign neglect if you don't want to
help or you don't want to hurt
deal with benign neglect what's happened
with the republicans this year
is that they've created a program which
is designed
neglect right it's an actual plan not to
provide the funding not to provide the
help
for those families all those communities
mark he's so passionate the n95 can't
even stay on his nose look at that that
is passion
for that to put this extra burden of
putting vaccinations oh sorry not an n95
but without the extra resources and what
do they do
on the republican side they throw out
these
red herrings so many red herrings that
you need to build an aquarium
in the well here of the senate in order
to deal with all those
that gets away from the central issue
yes and no up or down
will you provide two thousand dollars to
americans
who are going to need it through what
tony fauci is saying
will be the worst part simple of this
pandemic
yes and no up or down where do they
stand on this issue
here's what we do know
republicans seem more focused on funding
the defense department than they do
funding the defense less in our country
right and americans are becoming more
defenseless
as each day goes by
the headlines are screaming
that this panic that is absolutely
understandable and based upon
fact is sweeping our country
there is protection which the federal
government
should be providing to these families we
inherit
they're hungry they could be
without their homes the addiction crisis
is rising they need help in their
families
you know one of the things i've learned
in covering
politics for a long time is
it's very difficult to get others
to care about someone other than
themselves if that's not in their nature
it's really difficult sometimes if like
their kid if something happens to their
kid
you can get them to care about someone
other than themselves because it's
you know someone someone that connected
to them personally but
you you really can't make others be good
people that's one of the big things
we're up against right now
they're having to make impossible
decisions to whether to put food on the
table or keep the heat on through the
cold winter months
and the united states government has an
obligation to help working people who
through no fault
of their own are seeing all of the
things that they care about
all of the success that they have worked
for and all the financial security
they've earned be washed away how much
are we spending by the way on the
guardians of the galaxy
and there's a debate over 600 versus two
i mean come on
come on guys the damage to these
families is anticipatable
we can see what is unfolding
dr fochi is telling us we're at the
worst part
of the pandemic and it's going to
continue
so let us act in anticipation
[Music]
louis pasteur louis pasteur used to say
that chance favors the prepared mind
right you miss a hundred percent of the
shots you don't
take telling us let us prepare let us
help families
prepare for what is about to
arrive just in massachusetts alone
21 000 new people applied for
unemployment insurance in the week
before christmas food banks across
massachusetts across the country are
seeing double-digit
increases in demand with families who
never faced
food insecurity before people are
literally starving
cold and without homes and meanwhile
the majority leader in republican
leadership would rather
head home for the new year and ignore
the financial
and health crises that are taking a toll
on our families for millions of
americans this will be a new year's
holiday
where they won't know if they can put
food on the table
that night this is just sport for them
that's what the
ed markey doesn't seem to get that or i
know he has to pretend not to
working americans would be too expensive
that would inflate our national deficit
that our budgets are already bloated
i have to ask though where was this
outrage
republicans blew up on national deficit
right to give a 1.5
trillion dollar tax cut imagine the how
do they even claim they're worried about
borrowing money
to cover the checks like how is that
even an argument when trump
set records for deficit growth next meal
will come from
the eviction notice on the front door of
losing health care
in the midst of this crisis and
americans are actually tired of being
told that 600
is quote sufficient as an amount of
money
as relief as billionaires receive their
tax breaks
and grow their wealth by the way great
job moderators uh
on youtube and and twitch just massive
dumps of ban hammers happening we've got
a lot of trolls in the chat they're
getting
very desperate as we get closer to the
inauguration of joe biden
and uh moderator's gonna have to be
working overtime on these
when they can see tax breaks going to
those companies that are actually
laying off workers and americans are
tired
of being let down by their government
time and time again
as donald trump and his republican
allies
have abandoned them during this response
to the pandemic
americans need support they need to be
able to trust their government and they
need two thousand dollars
now so that's the issue
yes or no up and down
on providing two thousand dollars to
americans
simply help them make it through the
worst strike and
strike all strikes so mr president
i ask unanimous consent that at 12 30
p.m on thursday december 31st
well he wanted to proceed to the
immediate consideration
of hr 9051 a bill to provide two
thousand dollars
direct payment to the working class that
the bill be considered
read a third time in the senate vote on
passage of that bill
without intervening action or debate and
further
that if passed the motion to reconsider
be
considered made and laid upon the table
and then immediately following the vote
on hr
1951 the senate proceed to the immediate
consideration of the veto message
on h.r 93 95 that the senate immediately
vote on passage of the bill
the objections of the president to the
contrary notwithstanding
with no intervening action or debate
is there objection mr president the
senator for texas oh god observing the
right to object
mr president speaker pelosi's
second bite at the apple so before we
get back to john cornyn
let me just show you uh i covered this
the other day this is just disgusting
he he's a texas guy look at the brisket
that this guy subjected his family to
look at look at this uh hold on here it
is
can you imagine being from texas
and claiming that this is a brisket this
is
john cornyn's brisket from from his
christmas it's
it's disgusting it's disgusting and uh i
i just
i don't even know how that is that maybe
that that shit's legal in texas but
i've never seen anything like it in this
pandemic
the median household in my state is
sixty thousand dollars
and the speaker wants to send
taxpayer-funded assistance to folks
earning nearly
six times that much even the washington
post editorial board
agrees this no self-respecting
individual would serve that brisket to
their family
receiving a paycheck during this
pandemic
like government employees and people who
simply by virtue of
their job have been put out of work and
not receiving any income
or maybe at best unemployment
compensation the speaker's bill isn't
about targeting folks who've lost their
jobs
or so we're going to mute corning for
now because i have things to catch up on
with you guys
uh they're all making the same argument
so they've they've picked up on this
meme
that yeah the the brisket is criminal
they've picked up on this meme that uh
the payments
aren't targeted they're not targeted
well yes they are they're targeted to
people earning under 75 000
and they'll say well but they're not
targeted to people who have lost their
jobs
uh no unemployment is to those people so
that's
in addition to they've not actually said
why we shouldn't be doing both they're
just saying that the payments aren't
targeted and that's objectively bad well
it's incorrect that they're uh not
targeted they are targeted
based on income it's just ridiculous um
i do want to say as we have breached
10 000 live viewers on youtube let me
just do some quick thank yous for people
who signed up on my website
gabriel baker new joinedpakman.com
member
rick carter karen grimaldi
fiona reddle clete
torres and brett arietta
okay and that puts us at uh
14. remember uh joe biden may make
my membership discounts illegal which is
why it's very important to grab one
today
this is dick durbin of their lives
two thousand dollars characterized a few
moments ago by my friend from
texas as speaker pelosi's idea well i
might remind him it was
oh sorry and i forgot to thank dj and
dimixed for the twitch subs as well
quickly as possible
and though i don't often come to the
floor to agree with the president he's
right
in this instance he's clearly right and
what will we do now
we are calling senators back together in
washington from
far reaches across the united states
this morning
i received some email and text messages
from some of our colleagues
hopping on airplanes at 6 00 a.m on the
west coast
heading out here to face a vote what is
this vote all about
the first is to override the veto of the
president when it comes to the defense
authorization bill
by the way i i think it's important to
address and i don't
you know we're not really missing any
the substance here is just democrats
want a vote and republicans don't and
we'll see where where it kind of
goes um there are some people who have
been sort of hesitant to say
hey trump's trump's right on 2000
he may be he may be pushing for it for
cynical reasons
or for you know to hurt political
enemies
but he's still right about two thousand
um
the six hundred dollar enhanced
unemployment that was done with the
first round of stimulus
that was really good that was a good
thing to do i think it's important that
we not
listen 99.999
of the things trump has done are
disgusting terrible things
he's a global shame he deserves to be
removed
and he's being removed and he lost
there's no
i mean listen you you would have to it
would be hard not to
just stumble across something that's
correct and so let's just say it like
listen
trump is actually right on this one
whether it's because he's trying to get
revenge on someone or hurt someone
whatever democrats are right on two
thousand and trump is right on two
thousand and republicans are wrong
it doesn't mean you give trump four more
years in fact he's already been told no
you're not getting him
um i i think i mean it's like come on
guys you know it's
there's no big problem here alternative
which has
any ghost of a chance to help the
families of this country with this two
thousand dollar benefit
the only thing that will do it the only
one thing that will do it
is this bill that has already passed the
house of representatives
the house is in recess when they're
going to return is uncertain
they certainly don't have the time to
work through the regular order of
business and consider any new
legislation
even if we could send it to them in time
which i believe is very doubtful
and so it's up to senator mcconnell i'm
sorry people are getting mad thanks to
glenn
coco for the twitch sub really bad
wizard and reggaetrain
appreciate all of you bring it to the
senate for a vote
let's have this vote up or down let the
democrats and republicans express their
will
on behalf of the families in this
country i couldn't agree more with a
senator from massachusetts and his
characterization
of what families face across this
country and certainly in my home state
of illinois
it just i just wonder if any of the
republican senators who are downplaying
this economic crisis facing these
families
have really looked into the issue this
morning
in the senator's home state of texas
they showed an
early morning television show and the
cars that were lining up for food banks
right long lines of people waiting for
food banks and they interviewed some of
them
in texas who told heartbreaking stories
of how they once were volunteers at the
same food bank
and now we're dependent on it for a
helping hand if they were going to be
able to feed their families
these were people who were not lazy at
all
misfortune has come their way and the
question is will we help
this is our opportunity today with the
measure to pass the house of
representatives
not some theory of some legislation
might be considered tomorrow
today let's have this vote today this
evening
when the senators have returned let's
determine whether or not this house
passed measure for two thousand dollars
is going to be enacted into law and sent
to the president who is clearly anxious
to sign it
that to me is the reasonable thing to do
in fact it may even sound like the
united states senate
taking a vote on a timely issue after a
debate
we do it so seldom around here i think
we've lost our muscle memory
when it comes to this activity in the
senate it's time to return to it i thank
the senator from vermont the senator of
massachusetts
and of course the democratic leader for
bringing this issue before us this
afternoon
but it shouldn't end with our great
speeches it ought to end with an
important vote for the people
with the senator from illinois yield for
a question
center for texas president i wonder if
the senator from illinois would consider
pairing their request for 200
200 000 direct payment with a liability
shield provision
that would guard businesses that have
been operating in good faith and
following the guidelines put out by
disgusting government poisoned pills
institutions and
preserve we'll explain this in a sense
reckless and willful disregard of the
rights for others
would the senator consider pairing those
two together i would say
in response to my colleague i know his
passionate
defense of the notion for immunity from
liability for corporations in america
he has introduced a lengthy bill on the
subject
i don't believe that is consistent with
keeping this nation safe during give me
a break
and certainly is not responsive to any
onslaught of lawsuits
the senator might be interested to know
that the number of medical malpractice
cases filed in the name of coven 19
since the onset
of this current pandemic is slightly
higher
than the total number of lawsuits filed
by donald trump
in protesting the results of the
november 3rd election
this is not a tsunami of lawsuits i
believe we can take
reasonable measures to support and
defend those corporations and companies
which are making a good faith effort to
comply with public health standards and
protect the beauty
beautiful his bill i'm afraid goes way
too far mr president
mr president i'm the center for vermont
let me concur with my friend
he's not on mike very simple question
you are concerned about the issue of
corporate liability i get that i happen
not to agree with you
you're entitled to your opinion uh-oh
you may or may not be concerned about
section 230 of the 1996
federal uh telecommunications oh this is
getting explained too
we might have a discussion about how we
uh protect
american democracy it's a good
discussion as well yeah but i have this
strong feeling
senator cornyn that in texas is in
vermont you know what
people are really not talking about
corporate liability
i don't think they're talking about
section 230
what i think they are talking about here
we go senator from illinois just said
how they're going to feed their kids
today that is the issue
rescued microphone and what i would ask
my friend
from texas beautiful is what
is your problem with allowing the senate
to vote on whether or not
we are going to allow americans working
class people to get a 2 000
check now i gather that when that vote
comes to the floor and i hope it comes
immediately
you'll vote no and you'll explain to the
people of texas why you voted that way
that's
possible i respect that
but what is your problem
with allowing the senate to have a free
standing vote there are a number of
people on your side
republicans who already come forward and
say yeah they want to vote for this two
thousand dollar check
right now if you want to deal with
corporate liability that's fine let's
deal with it at some point
separate bring forth the bill we can
vote on it up and down
all that we are asking for is a simple
up or down vote on the issue
that tens of millions of people are
talking about right now
will they survive economically bernie's
in the midst of this terrible pandemic
so i asked
my colleague from texas what is the
problem
with allowing the u.s senate to vote on
the bill
passed by the house and i yield to my
colleague from texas
right president the center for texas
mr president i would say to uh our
colleague from vermont
um i have no problem with providing
assistance
whether it's to public health officials
are trying to
struggle with this pandemic or to
provide money for the research for
therapeutics or i think we just
witnessed the murder distributed around
the country i have no objection to
direct payments
to to individuals i voted for the twelve
hundred dollar direct payment
contained in the cares act i voted for
the additional money that's provided for
in the most recent
covet 19 legislation but this
legislation that the
senator from vermont is advocating would
benefit
households with annual income over three
hundred and fifty thousand dollars
they would get this money and i would
say that
one way to deal with this because of
course we negotiated back and forth on
the last coven 19 bill
nobody got everything what's the math of
that i thought it was just 75k or 150
for a couple where is he getting that
it would go to people earning 350
anybody know people making up to 350
000 why not couple it i just don't have
ability protection for
people who are acting in good faith this
isn't just about corporations
and our colleagues across the aisle so
let me explain what's going on now now
that we're we're understanding
the situation so what republicans want
to do is they want to do a poison pill
uh so that democrats don't agree to join
these two things democrats just want to
vote on increa you keep everything the
same
but payments go from 600 to 2000. no
no big just a disagreement on a number
very simple
what republicans want to add in is an
immunity shield to corporations
for what is essentially you know they
say who have
done the right thing but they basically
want it to be so that if customers or
employees get coveted because a business
opens when it shouldn't and does things
it shouldn't do that you can't sue them
for that
now what they of course ignore
is that we have a system now where if a
lawsuit
is frivolous it's thrown out in other
words without
passing any blanket immunity just with
the law as it is now
if you sue a business and say
i got coveted here and i want to sue you
you still have to prove that there was
negligence and so you don't actually
need that law it's a handout to
corporations let me get back to bernie
it's a legitimate debate
you know what bring it to the floor
let's vote it up or down i will vote
against it you will vote for it
right separate them but i ask you a very
simple question not
linking things together nobody in the
real world understands that stuff not
going to answer
that's inside the beltway stuff
what people in the real world know and i
want to take a moment
to read some of these statements yes
because uh we sent out we have a lot of
people on our social media
and we asked the american people we just
the other day we said tell me what would
a two thousand dollar
check mean to you what's going on in
your lives
and in just over 24 hours i would say to
my friend from texas
nearly 6 000 people responded
and here is just what a few of them had
to say and i
we don't have this is twitter stuff so i
don't have their names here and i
wouldn't use it publicly anyhow but
this is what they say one person writes
two thousand dollars is the difference
between keeping our apartment and being
evicted
here's another two thousand dollars
means i can afford to feed my three kids
response quote it would mean not having
to choose between renting groceries and
not having to ration
ration my pot is ned's end quote
another response quote i am raising my
grandfather
i am four thousand dollars behind on
utilities
we need electricity to run his medical
equipment end quote
here's another response two thousand
dollars would mean i wouldn't have to
worry about making my mortgage payment
this month
and then i could get my medication end
quote
another response two thousand dollars
would mean paying my rent and getting
life saving treatment
because i can't afford the fifty dollar
copay through my work insurance
just to see my neurologist right now can
you imagine quote and on and on and on
thousands of people responding
so i want to get back to the point that
i want to again ask my friend
from texas a lot of concern about
corporate liability
good issue bring it to the floor let's
vote on corporate liability
i would yield i would build for a
question from my friend from
illinois yield for a question through
the chair i've listened to the figures
that have been used on the floor about
families that could qualify for the two
thousand dollars
it's my understanding that an individual
with an income of seventy five thousand
dollars or less
could qualify for the two thousand
dollar payment right and a joint return
husband and wife two thousand dollars
could be given to them
if their income is under a hundred and
fifty thousand dollars
is that your understanding understanding
and i think you know as republicans do
they're gonna
let it be but here's i'll get back to my
friend my friend from texas
senator cornyn we're asking this simple
question you want to bring up
corporate liability bring it up you want
to bring up
section 230 bring it up you want to
bring up the
moon bring it up but what the american
people want now
is an up without no vote now you're
going to vote against it if it comes to
the vlog that's fine
you're right but the people of texas i
will vote for
but all that i am asking for is the
right
as a united states senator to have the
vote
and again i ask you what is your problem
with members of the united states senate
including
a number of republicans who have already
indicated they would like to vote for
this
what's your problem with bringing that
up as a
single standalone bill not merged with
corporate liability or anything else
what's your problem with that
mr president senator for texas mr
president
i would say to our colleague from
vermont this money is not targeted
to people who suffered financial
offenses yeah we heard that targeted to
people who suffered financial losses
it's targeted to people making under 75
000. if they meet the financial
requirements
other government employees who've
suffered no financial loss during this
pandemic you i mean we can't this is not
a both sides thing right guys like i
mean
this is a disgusting individual this is
this is a vile
vile person government employees have
been receiving their full paycheck
during this pandemic that's a good
question and then i will have to explain
that to the people of the state of
response
the center for texas has the floor uh he
asked me a question as i understood it
the center for texas john did you ask me
a question did i
the center for texas it was more of a
rhetorical question mister
oh it was retaliation for texas mr
president i wanted to come to the floor
and talk about
what strikes me as something akin to
groundhog day
yeah um trump's getting tagged on
twitter porn it's something i feel like
we're living through here
uh as we debate the same points over and
over
and over again because they don't have a
vote he's like why do we keep debating
the same thing all right we could just
vote and be done with it but
which you won't do partisan basis we've
already
appropriated roughly four trillion
dollars
in response to this pandemic and it's
appropriate
that we have done so because this was a
true public health crisis
but now this is uh we're seeing we're
seeing uh politics
yeah guys can't you tell that like when
they did the money stuff before
things were bad but we're kind of
dealing with it now okay isn't it
obvious from this chart that like we
don't really need
that much more money isn't it very clear
like i mean just look at the death
numbers right
you know when we did the money stuff
here obviously now everything like why
are we talking about money this is crazy
we've thrown small businesses and their
employees a lifeline
through the paycheck protection program
and we were right to do so
we've invested in research and
development manufacturing
all right so let's get let's get away
from corn in a little bit just so i know
there's people eating while they watch
and this is probably not good to listen
to let me just get caught up on thanking
people i want to thank
big thank you to deflated brady and taz
for the twitch subs i love that and that
puts us at 21 and then
in all seriousness huge thank you a
bunch of people just signed up on my
website with that great discount
i want to say thanks to ben barringer um
espen langvik marianne
nielsen bear madison as well as
jerome robbins and deborah montgomery
which puts us at uh 27 i really
appreciate that
i know we're we're getting to the end of
the year here and uh really appreciate
folks who are
uh who are signing up let me read a few
of the
super chats uh we'll get cornyn's just
not answering so we'll get back to him
victoria via super chat liking bernie
feel the burn god bless you for
continuing to fight in the u.s senate
captain mice says i love the fact that
mitch calls it borrowed money because
it's not i see it as a tax break of 2000
for most american people i love your
show david greeting from the netherlands
matt says section 230 has always been
tied to the defense bill
hence the veto election fraud deals more
with national defense
fix the defense bill furocker
says that a john cornyn's brisket is
absolutely
not legal uh in texas yeah that's good
to know
it certainly wouldn't be legal in my
house somebody tries to bring that in
that is just not happening
and radicand says this should be a
no-brainer and a bill is not even
necessary to vote and a bill not even
necessary to vote on
sad effing lot that can't empathize
as you say david simple
uh republicans see rising numbers on
charts meaning a chance to get rich
we need a robin hood and the first
aquarius says just because one hasn't
lost
a job doesn't mean they haven't suffered
financially
parents have taken time off from work
because kids are out of school
yeah but not only that i think there's
another important aspect of this
um you can have a
think this is the money is demand side
stimulus
you can have a business type like for
example a restaurant
that even though its customers may be
doing
okay financially the restaurant because
a lack of demand
has seen dramatically decreased revenue
so one of the things you can do is you
give people money to spend in their
local businesses it's called
it's called demand side stimulus so
there's a whole bunch of other
aspects to this that it's not clear that
they don't understand
or if they don't care or you know if
they pretend not to unders
i don't really know but yes that's
something we've talked about many times
before
in recent days the president has
expressed an interest in doing more
and i have no doubt that we will do more
in this area
but speaker pelosi's bill goes far
beyond what the president is talking
about
for one it would wide it would
dramatically widen the pool of
recipients enabling wealthy households
to qualify for relief checks this is
unacceptable
and wasteful when congress provided the
first round of direct payments through
the cares act we did so in a way that
sent relief to the hardest hit americans
individuals who made up to 75 000
received the full twelve hundred dollars
and the amount gradually declined as
income increased and completely phased
out
at ninety nine thousand dollars we kept
the same formula for the six hundred
dollar payments provided for under the
omnibus
and further targeted the relief once
again those who made up the seventy five
thousand dollars will receive the full
amount
and the amount phases out completely at
eighty seven thousand dollars
under the cares act a family of four
earning up to one hundred and fifty
thousand dollars received thirty four
hundred dollars
in the most recent rescue bill the same
family would receive an additional
twenty four hundred dollars this was the
most effective and targeted way to
ensure that assistance goes
to those who actually need it while
avoiding sending taxpayer dollars
borrowed i might add oh no to those who
don't
borrowed the house passed legislation
would provide two thousand dollar
payments
but it doesn't have a similar structure
to keep these payments
targeted let me give you an example
if this bill were to become law a person
making a hundred thousand dollars a year
would receive a 750
check from the federal government
whether or not they lost income
is it because of the phase out is that
what's going on when he used to make
that much but was laid off or had
reduction in their income
someone who's currently earning a
six-figure salary would receive an
additional
750 dollars from american taxpayers
for families the income barrier goes
higher as i mentioned a moment ago
if you have a family of five with an
annual household income of 350 000
a year that family would receive a
stimulus check
under the house pass bill now that's not
being smart
family i i just i'd have to look at that
i don't know i don't i really don't know
what he's talking
that's a giveaway to people who have not
suffered any financial losses
during this pandemic and clearly not
targeted at those who need
the most help i mentioned a moment ago
that the median income
for households in texas is sixty
thousand dollars a year
so this family of five is earning nearly
six times as much
and would still receive a check from
taxpayers
that defies all common sense
even the washington post editorial board
dubbed this policy is wasteful now
here's an interesting this is an
interesting uh okay
so inconsolable has a good super chat i
don't understand this argument i make a
lot more than 75k but if you give me 2k
it's all going to local businesses isn't
that the point well
i mean that may be your plan
inconsolable but
it's absolutely true that there is a
diminishing marginal propensity to
consume as
income increases and um
uh if you from it
it is generally true that as income goes
up
if you give x dollars to people
the less they make the more likely they
are to spend it
and the more they make the more likely
they are to save it now what's wrong
is a lot of the tweets that have been
going around saying you're going to give
2 grand to people and they're not going
to use it for anything because they
don't need it
that's widely speaking not true and
um but but there is absolutely a
diminish diminishing marginal propensity
to spend
and you know think if someone makes a
million dollars a year and you give them
two grand
um they're probably just going to save
it you know they
if they wanted to blow two grand on
something they already have the two
grand to do it so that
is accurate it makes it it is a it is a
proper economic principle
uh but it's being they're lying about
how the program works
they're using coded not coded but but
sort of dog whistle language like
borrowed money or it's not targeted like
well it is targeted to people that make
up to 75 000
with a faith phase out that goes uh
beyond that
um but but but it is true i mean i've
said before i didn't qualify
for the first stimulus i wouldn't get
any money from this stimulus and if i
did
like in either case if i got a check for
600 or i got a check for 2000
it's just going in my bank account i'm
probably putting it in a retirement
account and i'll access it you know
in 30 years or or whatever that is true
uh but they're talking about under 75
000 per person
150 for a couple i think maybe what he's
referring to
is um uh with kids it
goes up the limits go up i don't even
know uh exactly what he's what he's
referring to there
by seeing what works and what doesn't
work we can be
better stewards of the taxpayer dollars
by spending the money
more efficiently and in a more targeted
way
this isn't like notice he's been
repeating the same stuff for an hour now
we have an idea about what's needed for
individual programs
there was no precedent for this pandemic
no
handbook no clear way to gauge how long
this crisis would go on or what would be
needed
to sustain our response let's get a
little more volume here after the cares
act
we knew it made the most sense to hit
sense to hit the pause button and see
what worked well
what didn't and where more help was we
did it's been seven months
said there were certain programs like
the paycheck protection program that
almost immediately dried up
if i'm not mistaken in two weeks roughly
350 billion dollars
yeah what you guys are saying to me is
uh more interesting than what john
cornyn is saying so let me let me focus
in on that
um laura says in canada it was for the
for people who applied for ei
and could prove the loss of money even
small business flat rate that will have
tax deducted in january
uh carpenter leo says they're pretending
to care about wealthy people getting
more money
just so poor people don't get any yeah
they've very very well said
junior extreme says we are like in an
abusive relationship where we praise our
officials for doing the bare minimum i
love how this argument of where the
money never happens
when it's for tax breaks or military
funding of course
of course yeah we've been covering that
for a while uh the gop is doing their
part to take the happy out of the new
year
oliver says stumbled across your show a
few months ago love it and your dry
humor
lots of strength from switzerland we're
all in this together thank you i love
switzerland would love to get back there
soon um and then i already got
that one okay good so i think i'm caught
up as far as that goes
for bizilla says my sister is
self-employed hair stylist two thousand
dollars is the difference between her
being able to afford to live if we have
another shutdown here in alaska or not
inconsolable says i don't know two
thousand bucks in seattle is a lot
different than two thousand dollars in
detroit
75k is not wealthy here they really need
to take into account cost of living a
lot of 75k
income people here are struggling well
it's it starts to phase out at 75
so you would still get money at 75
inconsolable
um andrew says it's cute that corn in a
multi-millionaire thinks a couple making
175
is wealthy and mh says i'd love to see
him give some numbers on how many
american families would qualify for what
he's so concerned about it's all
hypothetical bs
right that would be interesting like
what percentage of families
of all of the recipients that would
qualify
what what tranches of money would go to
what sized cohorts that would be
that may have been done already that may
have been done
thanks to zimbardo brie and
bremen gibb for the twitch subs which
puts us at
29 i also want to say thank you to oh
wow bunch of new members
jacqueline blanche has signed up at
joinpackman.com
chad mcvay a real chad
um tony subia elena menardo
bonnie huntington and ryan carson all
have signed up
which puts us at 35 let's get back to
the proceedings
mr president the senator for ohio
thank you mr president um for a lot of
revisionist history this afternoon
sherrod brown let's try it in march when
congress did the right thing the senate
voted unanimously
because of our efforts 13 million people
were kept out of poverty we know that
because we did
we did gen relatively generous
unemployment insurance we did the direct
payments we helped with small business
loans
but then this senate thought its work
was done for the year
we begged senator mcconnell month after
month after month to come back and help
as i said 13 million people were kept
out of poverty
because of the work this congress did in
march
of this year but now
since many of these benefits especially
the unemployment benefit
and the direct payments were not
continued of course
those benefits expired in august and
we have seen eight million people drop
into poverty in this country
since and yet this congress senator
mcconnell refused
and refused and refused i i hear this
revisionist history that
that democrats just want to help people
that are already affluent give them more
money
well remember back in march the only
amendment that we considered the only
amendment
by the way consider the irony that
republicans are saying this bill would
give
too much money to people who are wealthy
and don't need it
but they want a blanket liability
protection for
huge corporations even if employees get
covered because they're forced to come
into work
that's a handout to even richer people
like it's it you
it's also it's it's disgusting in spite
of senator cornyn and others comment
senator mcconnell waited waited waited
waited
finally we were able to do that the
president united states threatened to
veto it
causing millions of americans to fall
off their unemployment insurance i mean
we know all that it's just important to
remember all that
but there's one simple question before
the senate this week
we're going to put more money in
people's pockets the american people
made it clear
on election day they want a government
that's on their side this
is our chance to deliver for them to
show people whom we serve that we can
make a real
difference in their lives which we did
back in march
it's pretty simple the best not seeing
closed captions people asking for closed
cap oh here we go here we've got him
very good
which we did back in march it's pretty
simple the best way
to help ohio workers and families is put
more money than possible not in the bank
accounts
just corporations and the biggest banks
hoping it will trickle down we know it
never does
the ceos just pay themselves instead we
know mr president
just recently more good news for
america's ceos
who are able again to do stock buybacks
more
dividend distributions a lot of
corporations have made a lot of money
during more power to them during this
pandemic but those are the corporations
that continue to get the big tax breaks
we need to instead directly invest in
people who make this country work
it helps people pay the bills and stay
in their homes and get through this
downturn
it injects money into local economies
that really need it
the more money people have the more they
spend in small businesses that are
hurting
we know there's the demands we came
together
we across the aisle past the cares act
expanded unemployment
did direct stimulus tax checks keeping
13 million people out of poverty
the bill we passed last week was a good
step in that direction
but we should make it stronger back in
march
my original plan that i tried to
negotiate as i
sat with secretary mnuchin and and a
handful of other senators
was a two thousand dollars a week two
thousand dollars per person adults and
children we call for them
to be sent automatically throughout the
year every quarter as long as we remain
in a public health emergency
it's clear now what we could have done
and should have done
no one could predict how long this
crisis would last today we still aren't
sure when everyone will be vaccinated
when the economy
will return to full strength we don't
want to sit idly by we don't want to
wonder
how bad it could get we're the strongest
richest country on earth we have the
resources to do something about it
we just need leadership willing to use
every tool we have
if they refuse to support this two
thousand dollars
per person if they refuse to support
this these direct payments
leader mcconnell and senate republicans
will again make it perfectly
clear for the american people whose side
they're on every time there's a fork in
the road
and senator mcconnell and senate
republicans have to make a decision
either go with corporate interests or go
with working families every single time
they choose corporate interest they had
no problem pouring money
into corporate coffers with their tax
cut and blowing up the deficit i
remember mr president
uh just down the hall here you can do
senator mcconnell's office
i remember a lobbyist lining up looking
for those tax
cuts back three years ago and they got
those tax cuts they
they didn't say anything about
government deficits for people worried
about his voice his voice is always like
this this is his normal voice
he sounds fine to me going into into
their contributors pockets into big
corporate
corporate
coffers into the wealth for the
wealthiest people in this country
they were all too happy to let the
government shovel loans to the biggest
banks and companies
but in the middle of the worst crisis of
our lifetimes faced with a chance
to give money directly to our ordinary
americans my colleagues claim we can't
afford it that's just
simply a lie we're the richest country
on earth i remember bill spriggs
economist at howard university told the
banking and housing committee in
september
we didn't win world war ii by worrying
whether or not we could afford it
we're in a global crisis we marshaled
all our vast resources and talents
to rise to meet it we grew the economy
from middle class out we paid down the
debt with raising wages
if we've learned anything from this
crisis it should be that we can do the
same again
americans are tired of being told we
can't it's the only answer
that senator mcconnell and senate
republicans ever have with people's most
people's problems
we can't help you we can't solve your
problem you're on your own
let's aim higher let's deliver for the
people we serve let's put two thousand
dollars
into their pockets money that will make
such a difference for so many families
it will help a mother worried about how
she'll pay back rent it'll keep a laid
off
restaurant worker from turning to a
payday lender it will allow a father
to buy a new computer so his kids are
better able to learn online
there are millions these are millions of
real people people we swore an
oath to serve who would breathe a little
easier this new year's
if we pass this so let's be clear about
the decision
today and this week before the center
are we going to give the people
we serve two thousand dollars are you
going to stand in the way
sadly they're not let's come together
let's pass this let's make a real
difference
in people's lives
there's sherrod brown senator from ohio
clerk will call the roll mr alexander
okay they're in the middle of a roll
call so i will um
uh proceed with some of our business
thanks to
michael wood and sheldrake smith
for signing up at joinpacman.com
and thanks to squash nug and burger
prince
for the twitch subs which puts us at 39.
three very powerful streams coming up
this uh coming week a monday evening
we will be back fully back and
i will be covering for you what may be
donald trump's last political rally
ever in the state of georgia in support
of david perdue and kelly lefler
join me at 6 30 pm eastern time monday
uh everywhere that we stream on tuesday
evening
join me at 7 p.m as we start to get
results from the georgia senate
elections
tuesday at 7 00 p.m eastern time
and then wednesday at uh 12 i think i'll
probably start at 12 45
p.m eastern that's going to be a hectic
day i'll have to do the show
very early i guess so that then we can
get to
the official counting of the electoral
votes presided over by mike president
vice president mike pence
i like that mike president vice pence i
like that
um and he is we are expecting uh
objections from both republican members
of the house
and republican senator josh hawley
which will trigger for lack of a better
term a two-hour debate in the house a
two-hour debate in the senate
as to whether there will be objections
from the standpoint of accepting
those votes so that will be wednesday
around 1 pm eastern time and i hope you
will join me
for that andrew says republicans have
given trillions of dollars to
billionaires over 50 years of
trickle-down
middle-class wages have been stagnant
republicans owe us two thousand dollars
a thousand times over shan
says millionaire republicans talking
like they can understand how difficult
it is to survive on 600
isn't this a bad thing for the georgia
runoff honestly
i don't know whether anybody down there
is paying attention
i really don't uh in other words are
republican voters
seeing this and saying i might not vote
for lefleur because of what cornyn said
i don't know
um move4me says just wanted to say
thanks david for the broadcast bernie is
an absolute savage
and so are you great analysis keep it
coming patriots
and walrisme says my r button takes
union breaks
sorry okay i see what you did there very
very much appreciate that one that's a
nice one
um they are taking a roll call now in
the senate let's listen
there may be nothing to listen to
thanks to jessica whittaker for signing
up at joinedpakman.com
appreciate it
thanks also to bad circuits for the
twitch sub it looks like sound is just
simply muted here as they call the role
in the senate um we have a couple things
we can look at in the meantime
yes i i did get a haircut this is a john
cornyn's brisket we already looked at
that
uh oh this is funny check out this like
crazy tucker carlson
they're trying to build like a cult of
personality around tucker take a look at
this this is from i guess the toilet
paper usa event
thank you guys
[Applause]
thank you oh yeah that may
work or not and he may end up being the
next republican nominee which is crazy
and then here's video of this
radiologist
scott atlas who trump had for a while
and his coronavirus
whatever uh check out i guess so in this
clip we're going to see him
encourage thanksgiving gatherings to
happen
and then say that the surge is proof
that he was right i don't even get it
let's take a look
and this kind of isolation is one of the
unspoken tragedies of the elderly
who are now being told don't see your
family at thanksgiving
for many people this is their final
thanksgiving right
or not what are we doing here i think we
have searches there was an initial surge
in november in los angeles county
and then unfortunately we had a great
deal of gathering and traveling
and holiday parties over the
thanksgiving holiday that created this
new surge
and it's really we know what's not
working and that's the lockdowns
i mean anybody who thinks that that's
something we should be doing
is denying that two plus two equals four
and this man i don't know what the he i
i don't even understand what he's
talking about that's just weird
very very odd guy glad that he's like
resigned or
quit or been fired or who knows what's
good he it's a it's he i mean listen
as a as a radiologist he may be great he
just doesn't know anything about
pandemics that's unfortunate
um as a georgian brian says i can tell
you
both purdue and leffler support two
thousand dollar
stimulus checks they said they would
vote for them i won't be voting for them
for either
for the myriad of other reasons yes well
said
so josh hawley junie mcgraw says so josh
hawley is less of a
right-wing populist and more of an
authoritarian sycophant
seemingly seemingly as he's willing to
stand up on wednesday and object
to the counting of the electoral votes
maggie says message to mr texas brisket
beater some who don't need it are giving
it to those who do that's called
compassion
i'll send you the definition yeah i
don't know that he would understand that
he might understand like charity through
his church or something
um i don't know yeah imagine hiring a
radiologist for covid response it
doesn't make any sense
uh it doesn't make doesn't make any
sense whatsoever
um it looks like they are still in the
middle of a roll call here
and it's not actually clear how long and
if this is going to continue they are
asking for the votes to be scheduled
for tomorrow for tomorrow uh so i think
that that's probably going to wrap my
coverage we saw some impassioned
speeches from bernie sanders
and from a number of others
so we are going to keep an eye on
whether there will be a vote and if
indeed they
get a vote scheduled for tomorrow
i will be back with you guys and
otherwise
a lot that's going to be happening into
the new year all right so i'll keep an
eye on this
if a vote gets scheduled i'll be here
with you
thank you for joining me make sure to
subscribe free on youtube
and follow if you are watching on twitch
where we are approaching 100 we're
slowly approaching
100 000 followers all right everybody be
safe see you soon
you